[Musique]
bienvenue sur d'autres exploitations
amont vers et bah allez je vais vous
raconter l'histoire de l'agriculture
comme je lé compris et vécu le souvenir
que j'en ai c'est les agriculteurs
s'étaient des mecs qui faisait pitié
bras beaucoup de formations pas beaucoup
de revenus habitants souvent dans des
maisons plutôt isolé mal équipés moi
j'ai connu l'électricité quand j'ai
passé mon bac à 1 18 ans le courant est
arrivé aussi un peu avant mais quand
même tardivement
souvent c'était le propriétaire qui
disait à peu près ce qu'il fallait faire
et comment il fallait faire
n'oublions pas que pas longtemps avant
on était en colonie on était vraiment
aller un peu de pub ou quoi moi j'ai
connu un moment donné où il y avait plus
de quinze mille producteurs de géranium
à la réunion il nous reste moins de 20
aujourd'hui
c'est difficile d'imaginer à 10 ans ou à
20 ans par contre on sait vers quoi on
va on va vers plus de qualité
on va vers plus de diversité et on va
aussi essayer de faire en sorte que
c'est sur toute l'année qu'on puisse
offrir une gamme de produits de bonne
qualité aux consommateurs
nous avions des responsables et en
particulier des élus qui voyait l'état
de cette population et de cette
production agricole est en gros on
s'inscrivait dans le progrès et donc
l'idée c'était de laisser aussi aux
agriculteurs accéder aux progrès donc il
fallait les faux mais il fallait
réfléchir sur comment leur donner de la
terre dans de meilleures conditions
comment financer ce qu'il fallait faire
pour produire et puis encouragé à se
regrouper pour mettre ensemble leurs
connaissances leurs envies et leurs
moyens et ça s'appelle des coopératives
et ça s'est vu notamment dans les
productions animales
c'est une vraie success stories con je
pense que les réunionnais ont vécu les
agriculteurs donc en particulier mais
tous les réunionnais en ont profité
toute cette partie là donc est en
conversion pour l'agriculture biologique
ça fait deux ans que c'est évident qu'on
n'a rentré qu'un mini pelle on a enlevé
toutes les roches
la rentrée du fumier du broyat etc et
c'est notre troisième cycle d'engrais
verts on peut tous faire la réunion et
on le fait c'est ça qui est génial il ya
cinquante ans on était tellement dans la
difficulté qu'on a fait un pas que c'est
pas on en est fiers moi j'en suis fier
si aujourd'hui ça vous suffit pas et
bien allons-y
prenez qui vous voulez pour vous
accompagner
mais dites ce que vous souhaitez changer
dit comment vous voulez modifier les
choses et vous verrez que si vous vous y
mettez par contre il faut il faut se
lever tôt
il faut avoir du courage mais vous
pouvez y arriver
[Musique]